um hi everyone uh welcome back to the
second part of today's workshop
uh we have two more interesting talks um
the first top is by
kate wu from mit
thank you lee hong for the introduction
so i'm a relatively new faculty
at mit i'm in lids which is the
laboratory for information and decision
systems
the department of civil and
environmental engineering as well as
idss which is the institute for data
systems and society and i'll be
really excited to share some of the the
journey that we've had over the last few
years
sort of trying to see if this uh
what i think to be a really interesting
problem domain has
any anything to do with reinforcement
learning
and what we've sort of found is that
it's it's actually
pretty hard to find a real world
application
that is a good fit for reinforcement
learning which i think is
a good reason for a lot of
a lot more intellectual work a lot more
research
so uh what i'm going to try to do in
this talk is actually try to
convince you that there is a
set of really interesting problems
that requires a lot more attention and
hopefully this will spur
a lot of discussion along the
theoretical lines this talk
itself is not too theoretically focused
so there will be a few connections
so um the motivating question
that has sort of kept me
up at night over the last few years is
how can we quantify the impact
of technology on societal systems so at
first this may not seem
like it has too much to do with rl but
just to say a little bit more about the
motivation
the pace of change and the pace at which
we're introducing technology into
society is is increasing it it has it
has a lot to do with
how uh how quickly ai is developing as
well the extent to which we've
been been introducing automation into
our systems over the last several
decades
and as a result the complexity of our
systems is also increasing and this
is it's increasingly difficult for us to
to work with with
uh with our existing tools so let me
give
an example here so one example of a
societal system is a city so
this is a slice of society and we've
been adding a lot to it
so just in the last decade roughly
speaking we've added
smartphones we've added
high-speed cellular networks we've added
navigation and routing apps we've added
mobility on demand services like uber
we've added
advanced driver assistance systems like
tesla and then
you know upcoming in the future we have
autonomous vehicles
drones and we can expect a lot more in
terms of
technology in terms of connectivity
automation ai
introduced being introduced into these
systems and
this combination has some impacts on
public safety and health on economic
well-being on sustainability and
resilience equity fairness a lot more
criteria that we really care about but
actually that's not how we think about
these systems when we when we design
technology and introduce them we
actually just
build it and then add it to the system
we don't really think about the impacts
except for for instance the bottom line
of a company
and whether or not it's financially
sustainable to
even build the product so if we squint a
little bit
i will argue that the the city here you
can view as an environment it is a
dynamical system
uh that um has progression has has
internal
um transitions and has um uh
uh has some sort of dynamical evolution
over time
again if you keep squinting these
pieces of technology business models and
so on
you can view as as an agent that's
interacting with this environment
and then we can also view these impacts
as as a sort of reward
or an objective that one could
potentially optimize for
and then we might view policy evaluation
so for instance we might take
some of these agents maybe they're not
training maybe they maybe a company has
built them but we would like to know
the impact of these policies
on the system on the environment which
is the city
and so we can actually try to evaluate
the policy on this reward
and if we take it a step further we
might consider policy learning so some
of these are not fixed in stone uber is
a set of algorithms and
those algorithms can be updated and as
those algorithms are
improved can we also improve the impact
of these policies or these set this type
of technology
on the system okay so this is a really
this is very high level and abstract let
me give you one
concrete example that i really like that
inspires a lot of my work
um that i think will uh
helps to shed some light into what my
why one might want to do this
so i've been really excited about
self-driving cars for the last decade
and it's in part because of a lot of the
promise it brings in terms of reducing
traffic accidents
and you know
being good for the environment providing
access to
those who are unable to drive and so on
and one of the really compelling aspects
of self-driving cars is that it can
potentially save a lot of fuel
and help help reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions
over time and so if we actually look at
that
in more detail however um transportation
currently
accounts for about a third of energy
consumption in the us
and then if we if we project this
forward in time to
some arbitrary date which is when some
experts believe that
we can have fully automated systems
there's actually a really large degree
of uncertainty so we could decrease our
energy consumption by 40
but you know very similar works um
if you twiddle the numbers a little bit
then we might actually see a doubling of
energy consumption so
you know we might we might build this
system and introduce it into
uh into our cities and we don't actually
know which way we're headed
and so just for the curious there are a
lot of factors that go into
um whether or not we're sort of
improving or
or worsening our energy consumption so
platooning and eco-driving these are
sort of smart
smart driving strategies are enabled by
autonomous vehicles
that can really reduce our energy
consumption but there are a lot of
different factors these are very complex
and
the sort of culprit is that with
self-driving cars
a lot more people will end up driving
because it
it's a lot less taxing on our own time
okay but
what i wanted to dig into here is that
not only is this uncertain this period
this uh where we're headed
what's also uncertain is what's in
between
and these i i'm not suggesting that we
cast this entire thing as a
reinforcement learning problem
that is quite far from where we are as a
field maybe one day
but i believe that reinforcement
learning can actually help us
understand this transition in the middle
uh
the the points in between to help us
actually help us make decisions as to
how we can steer how can we how we can
inform
potential policymakers to help steer us
in the right direction as opposed to the
wrong direction
so we don't even we don't know what this
looks like we don't know if we could
have a straight shot to
a more sustainable situation
we don't know if it's somewhat
non-linear we don't know if there's some
non-linearities
okay so the first thing that you might
ask
when applying reinforcement learning to
a non-standard problem so we're not
talking about grid world we're not
talking about mujoko
the question might be where do you get
the data um
reinforcement learning has is very very
data-hungry
and simulation is sort of the lifeblood
of
our a lot of our work in recent years
so the good news i would say is that
we actually build our cities based on
simulation
there's a very healthy ecosystem of
commercial and
open source urban simulators
these will take some real world snapshot
and you know model it exactly uh
to to the amount to the extent that we
have
we have data and can do this at very
large scales
as well so this is sort of the good news
in the sense that we don't necessarily
have a ton of data but we do have enough
data that we can inform
simulations and models well enough that
experts actually are willing to trust
the results of these simulators when
designing cities when
designing where new new roads should go
how roads should be lengthened where
hospitals should be built and how that
affects the
shape of the city and whatnot so that's
sort of the good news
um now it's not then just
straightforward how you can
apply reinforcement learning to this
problem we still have to very carefully
define the problem so what i
it's it's somewhat tricky to sort of
project
down a very complex problem space into
two dimensions but
here's here's my attempt and it'll also
serve as
an outline for um for the key points of
this talk
so i will give two axes of of difficulty
so to say so the first i will say
is along this degree of autonomy so you
can imagine this to be
no autonomous vehicles and all
autonomous vehicles
there is a long heritage so we're not
we're not
approaching this from uh a perspective
where this problem has never been
attempted before and reinforcement
learning is the first thing that we're
trying
there is a long heritage from control
theory and stochastic systems
oh i'm jumping ahead of myself so just
to make it a little bit concrete we're
going to start out with a very very
simple system and i'll give another axis
of difficulty later on
so this very simple system you might
consider to be a run one road
uh whether it's a circle or not um that
is
that's flexible but there are very very
few vehicle vehicles on it one to twenty
this is not so this is still a very toy
system this is not something that you
would ever see in in real life
but it is a model of uh it is a
simplification of something that you
might see in real life
and so you might have um such a scenario
with no autonomous vehicles and
you might have a scenario with all
autonomous vehicles
okay and then now drawing from those
long heritage from control theory
we actually have a lot of tools to
analyze fairly
fairly simple systems with fairly low
concentration of autonomy
as well as from from stochastic systems
on
on the other end so we actually have and
i i guess i want to make a comment that
what makes these systems feasible
uh up to this point is that it's not
that we're solving the problem in full
but that we're actually
willing to assume or constrain the
problem
such such that we have low uncertainty
and rewards
so for instance we might consider a
simple system
we might consider a pid control
controller and we might
consider that we're going to control uh
one vehicle and we're going to just
be concerned with the velocity of that
vehicle
and we want that vehicle to go fast so
we're constraining the
reward to just that one vehicle whereas
if we were to say
uh we we care about the whole system
that that then there's a lot of
uncertainty in in the reward
okay so that's that's sort of one point
that i'd like to make on the
on the low autonomy end and then um the
high autonomy end draws
a lot from from stochastic systems from
cueing theory so for example polling
systems and
yeah i should know i do i did not add um
citations to
this this slide but this this slide is
representing decades of work so if
anyone's interested i'm happy to send
you references
um so on the far other end
one might think that as we increase the
degree of autonomy
well we have more and more control
variables and then we have a cursive
dimensionality and yes that is true
but at the same time we have a lot at
the very extreme end we have
low uncertainty in transitions because
almost the whole system is determined
the the
say the credit assignment problem
becomes very easy
when every action you take produces a
result that
you can characterize very well and then
you can
you can actually resolve the uncertainty
quite well
um all right so this that's where the
first question
um in between here we actually have high
uncertainty in both rewards and the
transitions and we can actually consider
the scenarios on both ends where we have
high uncertainty and rewards as well
so um here we we sort of have a chasm
where we don't necessarily have good
techniques to
to to assess these systems so then the
question is does rl fit in here
rl is designed for for this high
uncertainty environment now we know we
have
we have simulator so we have infinite
data although we still don't want to use
infinite data
um the other axis of uncertainty is
along the scope of the environment and
you can roughly think of this in terms
of the number of vehicles the road
network and there are a lot of other
dimensions but this is
this is sufficient for the purposes of
this talk and so we might consider
something like a downtown of a city with
500 000 vehicles
10 000 roads and so on and there are
again
techniques drawing from control theory
and stochastic systems that allows us to
assess
sort of the around the edges of these of
this
problem space but here we do really
suffer from the curse of dimensionality
as the system is increased increase in
size
um so i would like to point out here
that there are a couple
notions of curses of dimensionality and
the first of which
is what we're used to which is that
as a state in action space grows
we suffer from from that curse but
there's a more subtle one which is that
as the scope of the environment
grows there are actually combinatorially
many more environments that we're
interested in
so you can think about the possible
number of road network configurations if
you have one road versus five roads
versus ten thousand roads the number of
ways to
redraw a road network um is
uh explodes as well so not only do we
have
environments that are harder to solve
because the state action space is larger
but there are exponentially more
environments as well
okay so i'll get to this later so so
then that's sort of the second challenge
um
so what we're going to do is
we're going to start out very simple and
we do want to see
you know is rl suitable for this problem
so
just to be concrete our agent is the is
the autonomous vehicles and our
environment is everything else in the
system
we're going to be controlling where our
action space is the vehicle
accelerations for instance
um we're trying to learn a policy to
maximize some reward and
we're concerned with the average reward
for instance of the entire system and
not not the constrained
reward for a single vehicle we're going
to maximize the
accumulated cumulative reward over time
and we're going to optimize for
some parameters of some policy which is
a deep neural network we're going to
employ policy gradient methods since
we're dealing with continuous control
problems
and like i said we've seen a lot of
success
in very difficult benchmark tasks
but we're very curious if now this set
of methodology can actually
give us some insights for some societal
systems that
that we may be interested in so
if we take a look at this this simplest
case what we can actually do
is let's consider um
let's actually consider the some
characteristics that we can draw from
control theory
so let's consider in the x-axis vehicle
density
so different numbers of vehicles on on a
road and on the y-axis
the average velocity of the system and
we actually plot the upper and lower
bounds of the system
from uh from equilibrium analysis
and so i have a video for the lower
bound
so this is what you do without any
control uh
so the vehicle sort of start out evenly
space but traffic jams like quickly form
so you can actually see this backwards
propagating
wave is very common in in traffic
systems
the upper bound is something that we can
numerically compute
the uh we can compute this line but we
can't necessarily synthesize a
controller that will achieve this
line so one of our curiosities is when
we employ deep reinforcement learning
to try to control this system by
controlling a fraction of these vehicles
where do we fall in between these bounds
so what we um there is some sort of
there's some recent work that
um hand designs a proportional integral
controller that sort of falls in between
here when uh
one one vehicle out of the system is
controlled
one vehicle is observed and
we do the same but now we're employing
policy gradient methods so it's not hand
designed
we're using an mlp controller
and i'll just sort of play the result of
the learned
controller so the the poli the learn
policy is currently off so that we can
actually
see the these backwards propagating
waves form again
and then at this line right here which
is now the
automated vehicle controller is switched
on you'll see it takes on a sort of
different driving profile
and it sort of opened up a gap and it
quickly closed it
and when it closed it closed the gap
there's um
the the backwards propagating waves are
are gone and actually this
resulted in a 50 increase in the speed
of the
of the system so
um when we actually take a step back and
we do this across the
across the vehicle densities we actually
see that the learn controller can
closely match this
this optimal velocity curve so sort of a
question on the theoretical side that we
don't have the answer to is
you know when can control theory and
reinforcement
actually be a really happy marriage here
where
potentially control theory can actually
provide these optimal velocity
curves uh the the outcome but not the
not synthesize the synthesize the
controller potentially
in what is the class of problems for
which
um you can have this nice pairing of
using control theory to actually verify
the optimality of
a learned controller because it is often
the case that in deep rl you don't know
when your if your controller is optimal
but in this case we do by borrowing from
from control systems another thing to
note here
is that which will segue into the next
part of this talk is that
the white regime is actually where we
trained and then in the gray regime
is also where we test and so
we can actually see that the optimal
velocity result
is closely tracked for these out of
distribution
traffic densities as well which is also
often surprising
in uh in reinforcement learning
um so
i will just skip over this but we can do
this for a number
for a lot of other settings the reason
we talk about the circular the single
and circular track is because
it is very nice and simple and we can
actually reason about
the optimality but now when we look at
now we're interested in this this sort
of curse of dimensionality as we look at
more and more complex systems
and a sort of motivation i like to give
here is that
uh no two cities are the same and even
if we look at two chunks
of like road network that are smaller
they're also likely not the same
it's possible that not even any two
roadblocks are the same
and there are a lot of reasons that they
could be different and it's it's a
combinatorial space we
we in order for reinforcement to be
useful for this domain we feel
very strongly that uh we must be able to
generalize
uh across across these elements across
networks so that's something that we're
very interested in
can transfer learning work uh in this
in this domain uh can knowledge be
transferred across these
these scenarios so for instance we might
have some source tasks like this
like the circular track does it have
anything to tell us about some target
tasks which looks very different
this can potentially help with sample
efficiency uh in addition so we might
try to just try to extract some
knowledge and then transfer it
and then and then and then we can even
continue training but
in the extreme case which is what we've
studied here
is zero shot transfer which is where
there's no uh training
um afterwards okay
so yep exactly um could uh we have about
two through three minutes before the
question okay thank you that's perfect
all right so uh just what i was talking
about before
here this is an example of zero shot
transfer between
sort of this density range and these
density ranges
because you can view these as different
networks but maybe that's not as
as exciting so here we have
another setting this is modeling a
highway network
and here we we're doing some training on
this
bottleneck network so you can see
vehicles sort of accumulating here
which we don't like so we're going to do
the same thing where we
um where we have a fraction of vehicles
10
and we would like to avoid this sort of
jam
up of the vehicles and there's this
interesting phenomenon that i don't have
time to
talk about which is called a capacity
drop
so as you jam more vehicles into the
system this is the inflow
the outflow should increase linearly and
then flatten out
but actually there's a drop so this is
called a capacity drop
where the vehicles are contending so
much that
that the capacity is actually lower than
this peak
as you increase the number of vehicles
going in
so that's all that's something that
we're trying to avoid here by
using uh some by introducing autonomous
vehicles
and we actually show that we can okay so
we train this just like we did before
but now we're interested can we reuse
this controller in a different network
and we do find that yes we can actually
directly transfer zero shot transfer
to bottlenecks of different sizes and
shapes and numbers of segments
we can transfer to different like
fractions of autonomous vehicles
and then sort of the most exciting uh
still ongoing work
is we can transfer to networks that look
very different so here's a grid network
which is sort of
our our like uh target benchmark right
now
um so we and we can basically see that
by training on a basically a highway
network
we can get a 26 improvement on a
uh grid network without any kind of
fine-tuning
so um so that's all i wanted to share
with you this is
just the beginning we're just scratching
the surface
i would say that we've done a lot of
work to really justify to ourselves to
convince ourselves that this is a domain
that
is uh that you know reinforcement
learning can potentially help with and
and that i hope will open up a lot of
interesting
empirical and theoretical questions um
and really get into you know can we can
we actually
in a way do some sort of counter factual
reasoning for societal systems
and there are a lot of interesting
questions in terms of scalability of
multi-agent systems
how can we operationalize these these uh
questions for the future and then how
can we deal with the human elements
uh in in this work so
um i will con i will end with that uh
but thanks to my collaborators and
sort of a conclusion slide
thanks kitty this is really interesting
problem space with lots of great
potential
um now we have some time for questions
open the floor for questions
i have a question um
you were uh you sort of hinted through
the talk of this idea that as you said
control theory and reinforcement
learning can have this happy marriage
uh and that makes perfect sense um
i wonder if you can elaborate a little
bit on
clearly control theoretic methods have
their strengths um what are these
these strengths and why is you know why
is not why is reinforcement learning not
immediately replacing these these old
methods of of course i know
they can't but i'm curious to hear it
from you
yeah so something i'd like to highlight
here i
i wasn't sure how to work this into the
talk is that but it's the questions that
i get sometimes is that
like in these scenarios i have the model
right i think there's some confusion i
they're
like we we talk a lot about model free
or model based methods here i
i have a model the model exists it is a
simulator
um but i don't necessarily have the
analytical form of the simulator
um but all of the control methods are
they're they're really deeply utilizing
the model
so they these methods have this
additional
information that is a lot stronger and
so
the reason it's not so far apart is
because here i do admit i have a model i
just can't access it
so directly um so if
if the control theoretic methods can
directly access the model even if it's a
more simplified form
than the model that i'm using this in
the simulator which might have a lot of
additional you know if statements and
um a lot like a lot more complex
distributional assumptions
um you know the control theoretic
methods
may still be able to provide bounds
uh through potentially even analytical
or numerical analysis
cool and we have a question from the
audience kathy can you
see the question oh using the q a tab
oh yes okay this is really cool work can
you talk a little bit about how the
simulation environments were created
it seems like they are an essential part
of the research even in the simple
circular lane
the natural traffic backup seems pretty
robust
yes uh creating the traffic and
environments is an essential part of the
research um and this is
not something we expected because it's
not it's really touched on in like
reinforcement learning classes
it is like the design of the mdp is
actually
where most of the time is spent what is
the reward function and that so that
actually
is discussed in some rl classes but
what we actually struggle the most with
is what is the state
um uh so one example in
as we go to more complex settings is you
know how do you order your vehicles
like how do you like when a vehicle sort
of moves from one road to the next
the ordering changes in some way
so um yeah so
the the discussion of you know what
exactly is the mvp that we're studying
is is a lot of the time and yes we
we spent a lot of time you know
interfacing
near commercials that open the most
advanced open source
traffic simulators with reinforcement
learning libraries
so that we can actually create mvps
um that that model the problems that we
uh that we're interested in then we have
to start very simple as well
um all right next question are there
research combining queueing theory and
rl concepts
similar to the combination of control
theory and rl i have to think so
i personally haven't looked too much in
that direction
um but i have to i have to think so
um can the current problem be formulated
as
a base series of graph-based neural
networks
yes i think so and that's that's sort of
the direction that we're
we're exploring right now but i didn't
have
a chance to share that today
and ask a question sure i'm curious
about this
the point that define the state space
was difficult um
i can imagine it's difficult partially
because you have to sort of decide am i
going to use like an egocentric view for
an agent or is there going to be some
other
view that it's going to have um so what
was it that made the definition of the
state so difficult like was there not a
natural
view for the agent um
there there can be so
then okay so like one difficulty is that
the
the agents are uh are changing all the
time
as well so vehicles are leaving and
entering the system at all
all at the same time uh or throughout
the episode
um there is an egocentric view
uh when we look at a a system where
we're controlling multiple vehicles then
it's not clear what the egocentric view
is because
like we could view it as a multi-agent
system and then everything is locally
observed
but we're also very interested in the
like the global optimum
as a centralized controller what do you
do and then how do you
how do you order the vehicles across the
across the roads like even
it like like one thought exercise is if
you have two lanes of road
and you have vehicles in two lanes how
do you order them do you like
do you order the for the vehicles in the
first lane first
and then add some buffer for of zeros
if there aren't enough vehicles and then
have a second lane of vehicles
so um so that so honestly when we
started thinking about these questions
the graphical networks were not as
prominent so now we're hoping that
graphical networks can help us
uh resolve most of these questions but
graphical networks have
a lot of scaling issues when it comes to
reinforcement learning especially
and so i think that's that's sort of
what we're um we're pushing on now
can we actually help scale graph neural
networks
in in the context of reinforcement
learning so that we can overcome some of
these
these issues yeah great question
fantastic um yeah thanks again katie for
the great talk and
uh i think now it's time to uh to move
to the next one
uh the next talk uh is by shine manure
from
technion